president Trump's son-in-law and senior
advisor Jared Kushner no longer has
access to top-secret material
White House chief of staff John Kelly
reduced the security clearance of
Kushner and other officials whose
backgrounds are still under
investigation
Kelley tightened the rules for access to
classified information as part of a
wider reform of White House security
clearance procedures major Garrett is at
the White House major good morning good
morning Kushner maintains an interim
security clearance status but going
forward we'll be cut off from some
highly classified information because
his background check is still being
conducted primarily because Kushner
keeps updating the information that
needs to be checked now Kelly's new
approach to security clearances has
affected about three dozen White House
personnel who've seen their status
downgraded she's a valued member of the
team and he will continue to do the
important work that he's been doing
since he started in the administration
White House press secretary Sarah
Sanders said senior adviser Jared
Kushner's inability to receive a full
security clearance would not diminish
his effectiveness or stature the way
that I try to define the president's
foreign policy objectives but Kushner's
clearance level was downgraded from top
secret - secret that means he cannot
read top-secret documents but others
with that clearance can summarize them
for him Kushner will also be denied
access to certain national security
council meetings and top secret policy
deliberations Jared Kushner's right in
the middle of that and he's an
extraordinary deal maker senior
officials say Kushner can still tackle
Middle East peace relations with China
and trade talks with Mexico counselor to
the president Kellyanne Conway said mr.
Trump will still rely on Kushner he has
great faith and Jared Kushner is his
senior advisor to continue to work on
matters affecting Middle East peace for
example in other pieces of his portfolio
but what administration official told
CBS News Kushner's foreign policy
portfolio will have to shrink the
relationship between Israel in America
is stronger than ever there are also
concerns within the White House that
Kushner who had no previous diplomatic
experience was manipulated and even
tricked by foreign officials some of
them preferred to
deal with Kushner directly but his
defenders say Kushner has more than held
his own sources tell us part of this
comes down to tension between Kelly and
Kushner and to a lesser extent his wife
Ivanka Trump now these clashes are not
nearly as intense or disruptive as they
were in the days when chief strategist
Steve Bannon was here but sources tell
us this messy issue of security
clearances has given Kelly an opening to
reassert his control Gail and apparently
he's taking it major thank you very much